Ich stelle mir immer eine Frage. Drei, zwei, eins, und ich sage ... Heim, heim, heim. Drei, zwei, eins, und jetzt sagst du ... Ka, ka, ka. Drei, zwei, eins, und ich sage ... Heim, heim, heim. Drei, zwei, eins, und jetzt sagst du ... Ka, ka, ka. Absolut, so ist es genauso, dass ich es auch. Ka. Hey, wow! Ja, toll, herzlichen Glückwunsch zu dieser neuen Folge. Stefan, Mensch, das war endlich das Intro von Klaus Badelt. Was haben wir lange gewartet? Es ist endlich da. Da hat er tatsächlich nach der letzten Woche Sebastian, da haben wir es auch, da hat er den Leberamt. Heinz, Heinz, Heinz. Ja, ja, ja, ja. Guck mal, Badelt, der alte Klausimensch, der hat es da rausgehauen. Schön, dass es da ist. Vielen Dank an das Intro, Klaus, Badelt eins. Ja, Stefan, du bist hier, du bist anwesend. Claudine. Ja, danke, ja, ja, richtig. Und? Ihr seid auch mit dabei. Wer hat es geschrieben? Jakob, Jakob Vier hat's reingedrückt in den Verteiler.
Alle haben's bekommen, schön, dass ihr da seid.
Schön, dass ihr da seid, vielen, vielen Dank fürs Erscheinen.
Florentin, ich freue mich, dass du da bist und mir gegenüber sitzt.
450, herzlichen Glückwunsch zu Folge 450, wir haben's endlich geschafft.
Warum gratulierst du die Hörer heute so offensiv?
Herzlichen Glückwunsch dafür, dass sie uns einschalten. Ich finde, eine Beglückwünschung ist eigentlich die beste Reaktion im Alltag, was man machen kann. Wenn du zu spät kommst, dann sagst du, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Und schon ist eigentlich die Stimmung wieder gut. Du meinst, wenn du selber zu spät bist, kommst du in ein Meeting, um anstatt zu sagen, sorry, sorry, Mr. Yakamoto, es tut mir sehr leid, ich habe es geschafft. Es gibt eine Trendwende, und zwar, es gibt Gabe den Trend, habe ich mal gehört, sag Danke statt Entschuldigung. Also wenn du zu spät kommst. Jetzt wirst du diese Alpha, Bier-Alpha-Bücher. Ja, absolut, Leute, ich brauche es dringend. Ich brauche ein bisschen Selbstbewusstsein. Und dann, dass du nicht sagst, Entschuldigung, sorry, dass ich zu spät gekommen bin, sondern danke, dass ihr auf mich gewartet habt oder danke für eure Geduld. So, und ich sage jetzt, wir gehen noch einen Schritt weiter, statt danke, beglückwünschen. Herzlichen Glückwunsch! Dass ihr mit meiner Anwesenheit prämiert werdet. Dass ihr es geschafft habt, vor mir hier zu sein. Ah. Herzlichen Glückwunsch! So, das ist eine gute Stimmung, da gehst du in jedes Gespräch mal gut rein. Wunderbar, du weißt, was los ist. Wenn du irgendwo vorstellig wirst, du gehst zum Notar und du sagst, guten Tag, Herr Will und du sagst, herzlichen Glückwunsch zur bestandenen Notarprüfung, dass du es geschafft hast, sie haben es durchgezogen, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Du gehst überall mit der gute Stimmung rein. Erstes Treffen, du sagst, wissen Sie was, Herr Brechtner? Ja, was denn? Sie sind ein Macher. Sie sind ein Macher. Ich sehe doch, im Wartezimmer habe ich doch gesehen. Nee, für die Bestattung bräuchten wir eine Unterschrift. Die Diplome, staatlich geprüfter Bestatter, Sie sind ein Macher. Sie bringen die Leute unter die Erde. Genau, wir bräuchten jetzt nur noch eine Unterschrift. Mein Beilein. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Dankeschön. Sie haben so viele Menschen unter die Erde gebracht, wie vielleicht sonst nur, ja. So, aber du siehst, es ist direkt eine Stimmung da, es ist sofort eine gute Stimmung, die Leute haben Bock, es ist erstmal eine Stimmung da, es ist vor allem, ich glaube, Leute reagieren immer gut, wenn du in einem dicht, in einer dicht, dicht bepackten U-Bahn sagst, herzlichen Glückwunsch, sind alle sofort ... Dann würden alle sehr vertieft in ihr Handy gucken, weil sie Angst haben, dass da jemand sagt, es tut mir leid für die Störung, entschuldigen Sie kurz, vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit. Nee, nee, nicht mit dem Setting herzlichen Glückwunsch bürst du sofort so ein Oh! Wenn du in einem Restaurant singen jemand Happy Birthday,
alle singen mit, klatschen mit, sind dabei, sind zusammengezogen.
Gegenbeispiel Mails.
Wenn in der Mail steht Herzlichen Glückwunsch,
dann schiebe ich die so voll in den Müll.
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich auch große Probleme,
weil die Leute meine Mails löschen.
Weil ich sage, Herzlichen Glückwunsch zu dieser Mail. Oder am Telefon auch, herzlichen Glückwunsch, weg. Enge, enge Freunde, enge, sehr enge, langjährige Freunde drücken mich weg. Gegen Beispiel oder sagen wir mal Gegenvorschlag konstruktiverweise gemeint, statt herzlichen Glückwunsch eher mit einem Kompliment einsteigen. Also du kommst zu spät ins Meeting und statt herzlichen Glückwunsch zu sagen, ich finde es auch nicht schlecht, weil dann erstmal alle denken, wofür, und das ist sofort so ein Irritationsmoment, den so Hypnotiseure auch immer machen. Man soll ja so um Leute, wenn man Leute humanisiert, stellen die irgendwie so verwirrende Fragen. Was ist Regenteil von Blau? Und dann fällst du einen tiefen Schlaf. Und dann denkst du, what? Und dann wachst du auf in einem Schlafzimmer und denkst dir, diese RTL-Hypnotisere, mach mir Angst. Ich finde, Verwirrung ist ein guter Einstieg. Verwirrung ist oft gut, weil die Leute sind vielleicht sauer auf dich, aber wenn du die verwirrst, ist es erstmal so ein bisschen drübergelegt. Genau. Ich denke mir, was aber auch gut funktionieren könnte, ist Komplimente. Weil selbst in komischen Situationen mag man Komplimente. Glaube ich. Also, du kommst rein, ein Meeting, bist viel zu spät, du warst auch noch wichtig fürs Meeting und der Chef hat dir vorher schon gesagt, ey, wenn sie nochmal zu spät kommen, dann müssen wir uns mal unterhalten, ein bisschen mit ihren Eltern unterhalten. Und dann... Oh nein, bitte nicht! Und dann kommst du rein. Bitte nicht die Mutti! Nein! Nö. Und dann kommst du rein und sagst, grosses Kompliment, vielen, vielen, sie sind immer vor mir da, sie sind ein richtiger Chef, sie sind vor mir da und bleiben noch länger als ich. Dankeschön. Und sie machen das richtig gut. Andere werden ausgeflippt. Andere, wenn ich jetzt hier mal wieder zu spät durchgumme, wären Sie, aber Sie. Ich wollte eigentlich auch im Begriff. Dann drehe ich mich so zu den anderen Mitarbeiter, in MitarbeiterInnen und sage so, wissen Sie, andere werden ausgeflippt. Aber hier steht Herr Carlson vor uns. Bevor du reinkamst, ist er ausgeflippt. Und ist die Ruhe selbst. Siehst du diesen Kaffeefleck? Er ist ausgeflippt. Er hat mit einem Fusstritt diese Kaffeekasse umgekickt. Sagt vor allem eins, dass er trotz Chef auch noch Mensch geblieben ist. Ja, finde ich nicht schlecht. Gut, also wir ersetzen Glückwunsch durch Kompliment. Und wenn wir uns noch Kompliment durch Entschuldigung ersetzen, dann haben wir einen kompletten Kreislauf, den wir einfach den Rest erzielen.
Circle of life.
Love.
Life.
It's the circle of life.
Ein Diphtung.
Oh, life.
Life.
Ach, Walisisch?
No.
Life? No.
Life?
Im beides sind Sinne britisch, live. Ist das. Ja. Ich brauche ein Kompliment. Ich brauche dringend Komplimente. Mein Selbstbewusstsein ist am Boden. Wieso? Ich habe Merch. Ihr seht es, wir haben unser fantastisches Merch. Ja. Das habe ich jetzt auch bekommen in XL. Ja, das ist, was du trägst, in der Größe. Ich frage eigentlich L. Ja, was du trägst,
deine Grösse.
Ich frag eigentlich L.
Ja, genau, also
ich hab diese List ja gesehen, wo du deine Grösse eingetragen hast.
Und dann hab ich aber so gesagt,
dem Management hab ich so gesagt,
ach, ich hatte explizit nach L gefragt und du hast dann entschieden,
dass ich stattdessen XL kriege. Du sagst, du trägst L. Weil du musst ja dann wissen, dass ich weiss, dass es grösser ist, als ich es wollte. Und das ist also, weil es mir schon ... Der fällt grösser aus, als er ist. Okay, dann noch ... Also brauche ich doch noch X ... Weil er ist mir schon ein Stück zu gross. Das Problem ist, sobald du X-A-Kleidung hast, denkst du dir ja, dann kann ich sie ja auch ausfüllen. Dann wirst du immer fetter. Ich bin kurz davor, wirklich 200 Kilo zu wiegen. Jeder Tag könnte ... Nee, im Ernsthaft. Jeder Tag könnte der erste Tag meiner Reise zu 200 Kilo sein. Ich bin unterwegs, ein bisschen spaziergegangen, in letzter Zeit wieder schön spazieren, und dann Landstrasse entgegengegangen, spazieren gegangen, und dann denke ich mir, boah, dass die Leute immer hier in Müll aus dem Fenster werfen, wenn die hier mit dem Auto vorbeifahren. Da liegt da hier der Müll rum. Liegt da wirklich Müll rum?
Ja, so Kekse,
so eine Kekspackung, so eine Plastikpackung.
Liegt da rum der Müll.
Moment mal.
Die Packung, die Kekspackung, die
Saar. Ich kann da nicht
widersprechen. Noch relativ.
Moment, stopp. Stopp, stopp, stop. Stopp. Langsam. Niemand sieht dich. Stefan. Wir alle kennen, sagen wir mal Roadtrip oder so. Roadtrip, einer hat eine Packung Kekse mit dabei. Ja, diese Cookies, American Cookies. Dann macht man die vorne auf und zieht das Regal raus, so diesen Schuber. So ist die Idee. Wir alle wissen aber, dass im Lauf der Packung wird die Packung auch noch bis nach ganz hinten aufgerissen. Die äussere Plastikverpackung. So eine normale Cookiepackung geht nicht so intakt in den Müll, wie sie da lag. Wir alle wissen, dass die mindestens bis nach hinten aufgerissen wird. Klar, es gibt diesen Schuber, die Idee ist da, wir machen nur an einer Seite auf und Schuber macht den Rest, aber die Idee ist oft nicht die Praxis. Also laufe ich da und denke mir, Moment mal, also die sah noch relativ prall aus. Und auch noch, ähm, nicht jetzt so mit Witterung versehen und Sonnengebleich. Ja, klar, so ein paar Regentröpfchen, ja, es war ein Tag, an dem es vor meiner Spazierung noch geregelt hat und dann war ich wirklich so weit und das ist glaube ich sogar schon der Tiefpunkt der Geschichte, dass ich, obwohl ich alleine auf einem Seitenweg einer Landstrasse war, Landstrasse kamen immer wieder Autos, habe ich trotzdem den, oh, ich habe was auf meinem Handy gelesen, ich muss mich umdrehen Move gemacht, für Autos. Als ob ein Auto fährt und sagt, warum dreht der gerade einfach? Warum dreht der Typ an, hundertmal an, wir fragen den. Entschuldigung, warum haben wir sich gerade umgedreht, weil sie haben sich einfach aus dem Nichts gedreht. Das ist ja mega unnatürlich. Ich bin eigentlich Nell! Und dann schrien sie Freak, Freak und fuhren weg Freak und dann der nächste Auto Freak. Und ich dachte wirklich, bin ich jetzt wirklich der Mensch, der sich wirklich für Müll, Müll umdreht? Und dann haben wir, okay, gut, kurz aufs Handy geguckt, drehe mich um, gehe zu der Parkung nochmal, Abstand so und denke mir ...
Ich finde diesen Handy-Move auf einer Landstrasse schon spannend, also dass man den jetzt pullen kann, Innenstadt, viele Kreuzungen, GPS machen manchmal nicht richtig mit, irgendwie dann so dreht man sich im Kreis und nutzt das Handy so als Ausrede, um die Richtung plötzlich schlagartig zu wechseln. So wie als würdest du so einem Navi folgen, wo muss ich hin? auf der Landstrasse, wo man schon eine halbe Stunde in eine Richtung gegangen ist, das Handy kurz hervorzuheben.
Ja, meine Story, Backstory, ich bin ja... So wie als würdest du so einem Navi folgen. Genau, aber auf einer Landstrasse, wo man schon eine halbe Stunde in eine Richtung gegangen ist,
das Handy kurz hervorzuheben.
Ja, meine Story, Backstory, ich bin ja Method-Actor, war,
ich krieg eine SMS im Sinne von, oh, das Haus steht in Flammen oder so.
Oh, dann sollte ich jetzt mal umdrehen.
So, nach dem Masse ...
Und dann ruft Ernst Busch an und sagt,
Sie sind jetzt zehn Jahre später.
Habe ich es mir doch anders überlegt, ich nehme sie doch. Und dann gehe ich zurück zur Packung und denke mir, so sieht kein Müll aus. Die ist noch recht prall. Also bin ich mir in dem Moment auch noch, ich trage normalerweise L, aber in dem Moment bin ich mir nicht zu schade, dann mal einen Drucktest. Beug mich also runter, die Packung war randvoll und ungeöffnet. Ungeöffnet? Ich wäre ja schon dran gewesen, wenn ich gesehen hätte, die wäre offen. Und in dem Moment dachte ich, danke, danke, dass sie verschlossen ist, weil ich weiß, dass ich sie auch gegessen hätte, wenn sie offen und im Gras geladen. Und du trägst normalerweise L. Eigentlich trage ich L. Und ich dachte mir, danke, lieber Gott, dass du mir diesen Scham-Moment, diesen ich hole noch mal alles aus dem Müll raus und stopfst mir in die fette Fresse rein Moment nicht gegeben hast, sondern dass du mir zumindest die Würde gelassen hast, dass es unverpackt ist. Und dann habe ich auf dem Rest des Weges die komplette Kekspackung aufgegessen. Und dann den Müll weggekommen. Also, ich verstehe das. Ich war nicht stolz auf mich? Ich verstehe das. Manchmal denke ich auch, habe ich zu wenig Ekel. In manchen Bereichen habe ich Ekel, aber in sowas wie Essensrest habe ich es auch nicht. Ich habe mal in einem Restaurant, das war so ein gutes Restaurant, wo alles wirklich toll war, auch das Brot am Anfang war mega lecker. Und dann war ich fertig mit Essen, hatte noch ein bisschen Hunger, am Nebentisch ist das Pärchen nicht gegangen und da war noch so ein Brot über.
Im Brotkorb? Ja.
Und da hat noch was, da habe ich
einfach mal reingelangt.
Aber hättest du auch, wenn du jetzt da so eine
noch so eine Viertel Lasagne
auf dem Teller
nebenan gelangen wäre? So, das Einzige,
was mich daran hindert,
das zu tun, ist
die Anwesenheit von Kellnern, Kellnerinnen, die da rumlaufen und sagen, ah, Freak, Freak, schau dich an, das ist ein Freak, das und dann schreit das ganze Lokal in Unison. Und dann musst du da so die Teller waschen, weil du erwischt wurdest. Aber ich hatte ja ganz früher, ich wollte ja früher Schauspieler werden und dachte, es ist eine gute Idee, an so einer Dorfbühne
dann auch mal so
mitzuspielen bei so Theaterstücken, bei so Dorfteaterstücken.
Und dann wurde ich da Regieassistent
und Lichttechniker in der
Personalunion und hab dann da so ein bisschen
gearbeitet und da war die Idee, da oben im ersten Stock
war das Theater und im Erdgeschoss
war ein Restaurant. Mach nicht Theater mit so einer
Geiste. Da war das Theater,
die Bretter, die die Welt bedeuten. Und unten war ein Restaurant und die Idee war, dass die Leute oben auch was bestellen konnten vom Restaurant und im Theater. Im Theater, das waren halt so Tische, eher so Tische, die da standen. Du konntest auch was essen, bevor es losging und auch währenddessen. Super. Und da war es meine Aufgabe, die Teller von unten der Küche hochzutragen nach oben. Oben gab es dann einen Kellner, der das oben dann an die Kunden gebracht hat. Ich war sozusagen nur menschliches Fließband. Meine Aufgabe war es aber auch, die Teller, die zurückgingen, wieder von oben vom Theater runter ins Restaurant zu bringen. Kattu, 200 Kilo. War genau so, wäre es bei mir auch. Ich verstehe das nicht.
Und ich hatte, wenn du Gehilfskoch oder so,
ich weiß nicht, Servicepersonal in einem Restaurant bist,
wie kannst du so einen guten Körper haben?
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Unfassbar.
Ich habe da wirklich nichts, gar keine Gefühle.
Weil ich hatte dann die Situation, dass ich im ersten Stock waren Leute
und im Erdgeschoss waren Leute. Aber die Treppe, das war mein Reich. Denn auf der Treppe war ich alleine. Und klar, da lag dann auch eine Pizza, ein Stück, wo offensichtliche Beissspuren drin waren von wildfremden Menschen. Hat mich das abgehalten, die komplett wegzuputzen?
Ich verstehe das genau. Es gab eine
Neo-Magazinsendung, damals eine der ersten.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was es war. Irgendein
Einspieler, es war auch irgendwie im Studio, live
vor Publikum, da war dann so ein
Kochen und hat so ein Essen vorbereitet.
Und dann wurde dieser Wagen,
einfach dieser Propwagen am Ende der Show
so weggeschoben.
Da stand ich dran. Und da stand ich
auch den ganzen Abend dran.
Ja, klar. Da hab ich einfach alles mir reingeballert.
Oh, Reste
sind auch das Beste. Gib mir Reste.
Reste sind so geil.
Aber sollte man da vielleicht
dann wiederum, passt gar nicht zusammen,
aber wenn man jemand so eine Trinkflasche hinhält,
ja,
so eine Sporttrinkflasche, die oben so zerkaut ist. Da könnte man in Peru im Urwald sein und dann, du hast richtig Durst nach so einer langen Wanderung, kein Wasser mehr und dann gibt dir mein guter Freund, nur als Beispiel jetzt, steckt dir die Trinkflasche hin, diese Nalgene, diese Plastiktrinkflaschen und wo er die ganze Zeit rausgesüppelt hat, niemals lieber Dursttot. Wenn das aber so ein geiles Softdrink wäre, weiß ich auch nicht, ob ich da nicht anders reagieren würde, ob es da nur der Wasseraspekt ist, aber wirklich, also da habe ich gar keine Bedenken, keine Vorbehalte, Reste von fremden Menschen. Vor allem, ich bin da auch wirklich ein Kollegenschwein, also ich muss auch sagen, keine Solidarität im kollegialen Umfeld, wenn es um Essen geht. Ich finde nämlich... Du meinst, du bist das Fressneid? Ne, also irgendwie, keine Ahnung, zum Büro oder so, wo man sich eine Küche teilt und dann irgendwie Kühlschrank mit Dingen, die offensichtlich angehören, stopfe ich mir rein, fresse ich rein. Ich finde aber auch, und ich weiß nicht, ob das edle Volk, das zuhört, die Geschworene mir zustimmen. Ich finde, sagen wir mal, du nimmst jetzt Eis, kaufst Eis im Büro und packst es ins Eisfach. Sagen wir mal einfach so diese Fürstpückler-Schnitten, so eine grosse Packung mit fünf Fürstpückler-Schnitten. So, die packst du rein, ist eins, vier sind noch da. So, ich komme an dem gleichen Tag, mache natürlich, check einmal den kompletten Kühlschrank ab, was da ist. Scans, scans, scans, scans. Ah, vier Pücklerschnitten, okay, alles klar, die sind vor Ort, alles klar, vier Stück noch drin. Du hast die auch hingelegt? Nein, nein, nein, eine Kollegin hat die gekauft, sagen wir mal, steht auch Zettel da, Kollegin. Moment, Moment, Moment, das hast du gerade nicht gesagt. Auf den Fürstpücklerschnitten? Auf der Packung der Fürstpücklerschnitten steht, ja, Clara steht jetzt Name der Kollegin und du weisst, ah, okay, alles, da die wir das gekauft haben, von fünf Schnitten noch vier da.
Ob das drei oder vier sind, ist auf, äh, bei diesem Gedanken erwischen wir uns gar nicht, wir sagen, ey, das ist ihrs, kein Problem.
Hier sind wir den Zettel drauf gemacht. Ja, den Zettel drauf gemacht. So, Tag vergeht, wunderbar, nächster Tag, ich komm wieder, schau mal, ah, diese Fürs-Bücker-Schnitten.
Gefrierfach auf,
vier von fünf.
Ah, die Clara hat immer noch vier von fünf,
von ihren fünf. Und dann direkt der Gedanke,
arbeitet sie überhaupt noch hier?
Direkt der Wunschgedanke, ist sie überhaupt noch hier?
Ist sie überhaupt noch hier?
Ich habe ja gar keine Informationen zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Ah, okay, also gestern hat sie eine gegessen,
heute keine. Aber sie hat trotzdem die Fünferpackung gekauft.
Okay, nicht mein Leben ist ein anderer Mensch. Tag vergeht, nächster Tag. Ich schaue wieder rein. Vier von fünf fürs Pücklerschnitten. Und an dem Punkt denke ich mir, nee, jetzt sind die Freiwild.
Du kannst nicht diese genüsslichen, köstlichen Schnitten dahinlegen,
mit deinem Namen drauf und dann so lange sie nicht essen.
Ab einem gewissen Punkt sind die vogelfrei für alle.
Leute hören diesen Podcast, um Zahlen zu bekommen von dir.
Ab wann sind sie vogelfrei?
Wenn es vier Schnitten sind, ab dem vierten Tag. Wenn es drei Schnitte sind, am dritten Tag. Am sechsten Tag. Nee, das muss ja ... Nee, Moment. Nee, lass uns sagen, fünf minus der Anzahl der Schnitten. Bei vier Schnitten nach einem Tag, bei drei Schnitten nach zwei Tagen. So, mein Problem ist ja, also, ich stelle mir im Kopf die Kurve vor. Sagen wir mal, sie würde jeden Tag eine Schnitte essen, dann hätte ich eine klare Überlegung, ah, in fünf Tagen ist die Packung weg, ich bin frei. Du hast ihr aber gar nicht die Chance gegeben, ein Muster zu zeigen, wenn sie jeden Montag ist Eistag, für's Pückler Freitag, sie hat den für's Pückler Freitag, dann kaufst du dir jede Woche eine Schnitte, du kaufst nicht die fucking Fünferpackung. Die sind billiger im Fünferpack. Fürs Pünferpack Freitag.
Nee, na, auf gar keinen Fall.
Nein, weil ich finde, jeder Mensch hat einfach eine begrenzte Menge Willenskraft.
Und man kann als Mitmensch, verantwortungsvoller Mitmensch, seinen Mitmenschen nur einen gewissen Grad an Willensstärke zumuten.
Darüber ist es auch wieder assi, finde ich.
Wenn du da so eine herrliche, du hast da so einen Schokobrunnen stehen, du hast einen Schokobrunnen, stellst du da in die Büroküche und sagst, ja, für Laura. Laura ist der Name dran. Und der läuft jeden Tag. Und immer wenn du reingehst, denkst du dir, der steht seit einer Woche, läuft der. Das kann doch nicht sein. Ich sehe auch schon, weil das ist so der Tiefpunkt meines Lebens, ich sehe ihn schon so am Horizont erscheinen. Er wird sein, dass ich am Filmset stehe und irgendwann in so ein Prop beiße. Ja. Also das kann sehr gut sein, dass ich mal irgendwann in so einen köstlich aussehenden Hühnchenschenkel beiße und merkekes-Plastik. Und, ja, okay, also ich finde es spannend, mein Problem an der ganzen Geschichte ist, und da habe ich gemerkt, da ticken wir noch ein bisschen anders. Weil ich finde, der Nebentisch, der war gerade auch schon ein bisschen Stretch als Beispiel, weil ich habe die die ganze Zeit gesehen. Es ist ein bisschen wie das Beispiel, was wir hatten mit der Hotelzimmer und Wohnungen, Mietwohnungen, in die man dann zieht, nach Leuten, die drinnen waren, funktionieren nur, weil der Informationsfluss gestoppt wurde, weil du nicht weißt, was da drinnen passiert ist. Und bei den Keksen, du weißt nicht, in welchem auch wenn die geöffnet worden wären, du weißt nicht, in welchem Auto die waren, du weißt nicht, von wem die benutzt wurden, du weißt nicht, dass die alle angeleckt wurden von dem Baby auf der Rückbank und dann weggeworfen wurden.
So, wenn du die Geschichte kanntest, würdest du wahrscheinlich auch anders reagieren. Ich, wenn ich jetzt das Pärchen am Nebentisch sehe, wie sie die ganze Zeit in dem Brot rumlecken oder was auch immer, oder generell eklig sind. Ich weiß nicht, was Pärchen so machen, ja. Ja. Oder in der Lasagne rumstocher. Ja, aber wenn man es nicht gesehen hat. So, und das heisst, so wissen, wer es ist, sorgt für mich schon für andere Gedanken, man will es vielleicht nicht so gerne an Reste gehen, und Zettel, also du hast direkt ein Gesicht dazu, führt bei mir zu Mitleid. Ich, wenn da draufsteht, Clara, da habe ich sofort, Clara hat sich von ihrem Geld, das diese fürs Pückler-Schnitten gekauft, schickt hin, bitte nicht klauen, Clara, Smiley, ein Gefrierfach. Und ich könnte das nicht übers Herz bringen. An Tag vier nicht, an Tag fünf nicht, an Tag sechshundert nicht. Ja, ist spannend, bei mir ist es nämlich genau andersrum. Wenn da jetzt steht, Finger weg, wird für eine Produktion gebraucht, eiskalt, anonym, dann ist es out of bounds, werde ich niemals annehmen. Nein, weg, essen. Würde ich sofort sagen, essen. Aber wenn da eine Kollegin ist, die sagt, äh, äh, Clara und so, und die einfach nach fünf Tagen noch nichts von ihren vier, fünf, fünf Pückler-Schnitten gemacht hat, dann ist meine Wut groß und dann esse ich das weg. Weil dann denke ich mir, nee, du bist ein Mitmensch, du bist keine Institution, du bist kein anonymes Produktionsgebilde, das vor sich hin rattert, du bist ein Mensch wie ich.
Und ich würde dir das nicht antun.
Du würdest lieber einen Mensch abstechen als ein anonymes
System. Ja, ich würde
lieber einen Mensch abstechen als eine Behörde.
Was mich natürlich
was mich natürlich
jetzt noch faszinierend interessiert ist,
was war die Geschichte
dieser Kekspackung? Also, um es kurz einzugrenzen, Nutri-Score E, erst mal direkt, vorweg. Das übersteuert sich mit der Vorstellung aller Leute. Und es waren diese American Cookies, die man so bei Lidl findet, so Lidl Aldi. Was ist der Durchschnitt Nutri-elscore deines Lebens, das interessiert mich. Weil ich bin auf jeden Fall im roten Bereich. Das ist meine Statistik, das sollte dir der Arzt mal vorlegen. Der sollte bei Tinder stehen. Durchschnitts-Nutfelscore.de. Der sollte auch nicht selber von dir eingetragen werden, sondern so von außen wie so ein Gütesiegel auf dir stehen. Genau. Ja, das finde ich eine sehr, sehr schöne Frage auf jeden Fall. Und ich finde,
diese American Cookies sind nie so geil, wie man immer
denkt. Weil du denkst immer so Cookie A.
Ich finde die nicht geil. Kein Fan von American Cookies.
So trocken, aber ich habe die trotzdem
alle weggefuttert. Was ist die
Geschichte? Also
ich weiß, also ich kenne jetzt die Physik
von Kekspackungen nicht so gut.
Aber wenn du die einfach so aus dem
Auto
lupfst, wie weit vom Auto entfernen die sich von der Strasse? Weil ich denke, ich würde erwarten, dass die auf der Strasse liegen bleiben. Aber dass die wirklich über den Gehweg und dann noch rechts vom Gehweg auf die Strasse ... Die müssen ja wirklich ... Also nicht jetzt wirklich athletisch geworfen, aber schon ... Was ist das für eine Situation? Ich kann damit ganz schwer jetzt umgehen, weil diese Variablen verstehe ich alle schon nicht. Also alle Variablen, die da drin sind, sind so ganz wilde Variablen. So unnatürlich. Ich kann nicht mit jemandem relaten, der aus dem Auto was rauswirft. Findest du es verwerflicher oder besser, als eine leere Kekspackung rauszuschmeißen? Oder gleich? Gleich verwerflich. Gleich verwerflich? Ich finde generell, Lebensmittel wegzuwerfen, wo noch was drin ist, schlimm. Aber es ist ja kein Müll. Es ist ja nicht so, dass du Müll aus dem Fenster wirfst. Leg die doch einfach auf die Strasse. Wenn du Lebensmittel kannst, kannst du ja verschenken. Leg sie auf die Strasse? Nee, ich meine, wenn du eine Kekspackung loswerden musst, weil du das nicht aushältst, die Gegenwart von dieser Kekspackung, dass du nicht bis zum nächsten ... Also dann leg die irgendwo hin, wo sie jemand sieht, ah, es ist eine verschlossene Kekspackung, kann ich sie wegmampfen.
Leg sie Leuten wie dir hin, leg sie, wie man so Pfandflaschen hinstellt, auf den Mülleimer. Aber da würde ich dann denken, nee, die nehme ich gerade nicht, weil die hat da jemand irgendwie, die hält sich jemand noch zurück. So im Sinne von, ich leg die hier hin oder so. Am Mülleimer hält die jemand sich zurück? Glaube ich nicht. Es gibt ja nämlich auch manchmal so, dass man so sieht, dass jemand einen Handschuh,
sag mal jemanden findet einen Handschuh,
sagen wir mal, jemand findet einen Handschuh und legt den dann an einen prominenten Ort, weil man sich denkt, okay, die Person sucht den Handschuh, kommt zurück und sie ist dann besser sichtbar, wenn sie da liegt. So würde ich das auch sehen, dass das schon jemand da hingelegt hat oder irgendwie so, man speichert das für später. Aber ich habe wirklich lange überlegt, was könnte das für eine Situation sein. Ich habe, das ist Szenario A, irgendeine Form von pädagogischem Eingriff. Von Justus, du darfst die Kekse nicht anrühren, bis wir zu Hause sind. Justus kramt scheinbar heimlich die Kekse aus der Einkaufspackung raus. Vater, Mutter, Justus, jetzt reicht's, wütend denkt, jetzt wird ein Exempelstatue. Reißt Justus die Keksebackung aus der Hand. Wir mussten die Aufnahme an dieser Stelle abbrechen. Aus Gruppen und Sauerstoffmangel. Wir mussten mal eine neue Flasche Sauerstoff aufmachen. Das ganze Blut ist aus seinem Hirn in den Magen geflossen. Ich hatte so viel Wasser im Mund, ich habe mich voll schluckt an dieser Situation. Köstlich. Das könnte ich mir vorstellen, Mutter, Vater reißt Justus die Kekspackung aus der Hand und sagt, so, und jetzt geht's aus dem Fenster. Spannend, dass dieser Vater offensichtlich, also erzieherisch, einen klaren Fokus hatte, dass Impulskontrolle, weil wir essen die Kekse jetzt nicht, ist ja eine pädagogische, eine Impulskontrollelehre, die war ihm wichtig, aber gleichzeitig wütend, in Kauf nimmt, wütend die Kekse rauszuwerfen und damit jegliche umweltpädagogischen Lehrzwecke aus dem Board werfen. Genau, das lässt mich daran zweifeln. Ich glaube, Fahrradunfall. Ein Unfall? Unfall. Okay. Achso, du meinst, dass es gar nicht aus dem Auto geworfen wurde, sondern von einem Fahrradfahrer, der auf dem Weg gefahren ist, neben der Strasse. Daran habe ich gar nicht gedacht. Fahrradunfall ist, glaube ich, jemand hat sich hingelegt, du hast auch gesagt, es hat geregnet vorher, da ist die Unfallgefahr höher, gerade im Fahrradfahrer ist ausgerutscht, dann entweder so verletzt, dass jemand dann kommen musste und dann diese Kekspackung blieb liegen. Und er hatte nur eine Kekspackung als Gepäck dabei, oder was? Du weißt nicht, vielleicht sind schon mehrere Menschen davor da gewesen und haben die Sellerie geplündert. Ach so, aber würde man, also welche Gegenstände müssten da gelegen haben, dass die Kekspackung als letzte zurückbleibt?
Goldbarren, das Bernsteinzimmer und die Mona Lisa. Und dann bleiben die Kekspackung als die zurück. Die kann ich nicht mehr tragen.
Naja, erst mal, wie du gerade schon sagst, die American Cookies sind überbewertet. Ich gehe da sofort mit. Ich glaube nicht, dass es die beliebtesten Süßigkeiten in Deutschland sind.
Die sind nämlich generell immer ein bisschen zu trocken.
Szenario zwei.
Roadtrip.
Freunde, ach so drei.
Freunde wollen Roadtrip fahren.
Und, oder, nie, pass auf.
So Bla Bla Car.
Szenario fünf.
So, Bla Bla Car.
Bla Bla Car.
Und zwar. Gibt es das überhaupt noch, oder gibt es noch diese Floske, dieses Wort? Nina will nach Bottrop Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,, BlaBlaCar, und zwar ... Gibt's das überhaupt noch, oder gibt's noch diese Flosk, dieses Wort?
Nina will nach Bottrop, Mexiko.
Nina will nach Mexiko und sucht BlaBlaCar und findet Jochen.
Jochen ist auf dem Weg nach Mexiko, würde Nina mitnehmen.
Nina denkt sich, super, wird cool, bei BlaBlaCar hat gemerkt,
aha, Jochen hat auch BlaBla aktiviert, ich unterhalte mich gern mit Leuten, ich lerne gerne neue Leute kennen, wunderbar, also fahre ich mit. Ich könnte ja, um die Fahrt so ein bisschen interessanter zu gestalten, vielleicht ein bisschen was zu essen mitnehmen. Ja, ich nehme die Cookies mit, ich nehme eine Packung Cookies mit, nur wunderbar, habe irgendwie ein bisschen was dabei, und dann unterhalte ich mich mit Jochen, lerne ihn kennen und wir naschen so ein bisschen Cookies auf der Autofahrt. Nina steigt also ein zu Jochen, ah, hi, wunderbar, Mexiko fest, ah ja, aha, wunderbar, haha, so, alles klar. Man fährt los, ich hab eine Playlist vorbereitet, und Nina meint auch, ja, ich hab auch ein Spiel dabei, weil ich mach so Geoguessing und wir können so ein bisschen anhand der Ortsschilder geguessen, wo wir und so. Okay, spannendes Spiel. Cool. Und ich habe mir ein bisschen was überlegt für die Fahrt. Nina hat Bock, Nina denkt sich, okay, hier lerne ich einen Freund fürs Leben kennen, das wird richtig cool, Jochen ist ein cooler Typ. Nina packt also die Kekse aus und sagt, willst du einen Keks? Jochen reißt die Augen auf. Rückt auf die Bremse.
Nee, nee, leider nicht.
Sorry.
Sorry, sorry.
Nee, nee, das sind die Momente, wo ich denke, halt dich zurück, Stefan, halt dich zurück.
Yes, fucking.
Weil da muss ich auch mal meine Presse halten und einfach dir zuhören, weil du weißt, was du tust.
Und ich will Beifahrer sein, und ich greife das Lenkrad. Und es tut mir leid.
Nina packt die Packung auf, Jochen reißt die Augen auf, schlenkert mit dem Lenker hin und her und sagt, bist du wahnsinnig, ich bin allergisch gegen Nüsse. So, Nina am Boden zerstört. Nina denkt sich, fuck, ich dachte, es wird eine coole Reise mit Jochen. Ich habe alles versaut. Ich habe es verbockt. Und aus Wut schmeißt sie oder auch aus, na, ich akzeptiere, ich will gar nicht dir was Böses tun. Oder aus, okay, gut, ich hab was mitgebracht und du willst es nicht. Ja. Schmeiß jetzt hier, also Fenster alles. Manche Aktionen haben mehrere Gefühle als Motivator, eine Gefühlsmischung. Nina ... Oder hat jemandcribnos gehört? Nina lässt also die Fensterscheibe runterfahren, was quälend lange dauert. Der Fahrtwind weht ihr ins Gesicht, die Haare ruiniert. Sie schmeißt also die Kekse aus dem Fenster. Die Kekse fliegen zurück ins Fenster rein, gegen das Gesicht. und dann einfach 16 Stunden Stille nach Mexiko. Und Nina konnte nie, ja gut, über den Brenner, Nina konnte nie Jochen wirklich kennenlernen. Aber was mich interessiert, haben sie noch das Spiel gespielt, wo sie anhand der Ortskennzeichen raten mussten, wo sie jetzt sind? Nina hat nichts mehr gesagt, nichts mehr gemacht und es war sehr unangenehm, sehr unangenehme 16 Stunden. These 5, Raubüberfall, Fussgänger, kleinen Timmy, geh einkaufen, geh schnell in den Ort, was einkaufen, Vater und ich brauchen heute Abend was für die Gäste, die kommen. Themen wird los losgeschickt mit Geld, Korb und wird losgeren, rennt los in die Stadt. Abenteuermusik rennt, kommt, aber sei vor Abend wieder da, sei um Punkt 18 Uhr wieder da, weil dann kommen die Gäste. und er läuft los, kommt zurück und an der Stelle eine Bande, eine Bande Banditen überfällt ihn und sagt, gib mir all dein Geld, gib mir all dein Geld. Er sagt, ich habe nichts mehr ausgegeben für diese Sachen. Und sie sagen, okay, was hast du denn hier? Dann gehen sie durch die Sachen, werfen alles und nehmen sich natürlich nur die wertvollen Dinge, wie zum Beispiel den USB-Stick. Den Timmy gekauft hat für die Gäste. Ja, genau. Schnell die Gäste kommen, hol doch schnell einen USB-Stick. V USB-Sticks. Einfach so eine Bowl. Einfach. Hä, ich habe so eine Bowl USB-Sticks. Stell was hin, einfach damit du was hinstellen kannst. Was zum Hinstellen in so Schüsseln. Ja, aber Harald, beim letzten Mal hat niemand einen USB-Stick genommen. Aber warum nicht? Ich habe Sachen drauf, gebrannte Songs. Auf einmal habe ich die Hellerringe, die Gefährten, Punkt MP4. Du hast auf die USB-Sticks Filme gebrannt? Nee, nicht nur Filme. Also das ist halt auch Bon Jovi-Album, auf einem ist ein New Two-Album. Aber die sind alle ungekennzeichnet, die sind alle grau. Ja, das ist doch der Spaß daran. Ja, aber warum sagst du das denn? Niemand weiss das. Es standen einfach den ganzen Abend diese Schüssel USB-Sticks da. Ja, und bei Tante Margret neulich waren wir doch auch, da war auch so eine Bowl mit so Chips drin. Ja, Chips, aber da sieht man was, da konnte sich nicht jeder was nehmen. Ja, aber da steht jetzt auch nicht drauf, was für Chips das sind. Ich habe Sticks, ich habe eine Bowl-USB-Sticks bei mir stehen. Aber Timmy ist echt schon lange weg, oder? Sollte der nicht eigentlich schon wieder da sein? Timmy! Aber Timmy? Ja, okay, danke. Für diese auditiv schwer einzufangende Schauspielleistung. Nur für dich. Der war nur für dich. Und dieser Lacher war es mir wert. Dankeschön. Szenario sechs. Ich habe mich nämlich leicht, das kurz für die Leute, die uns nur zuhören, nicht auch zu schauen, was er geht, auf patreon.com. Szenario sechs. Matthias geht in die sechste Klasse und findet nicht viele Freunde. Er beginnt das Schuljahr also Zur Seite, gut, dann ist Markus eben mein Freund, aber er merkt plötzlich, wir haben gar keine gemeinsamen Homies und dieser Markus, der kommt von einer rauen Schule, das ist ein krasser Typ, der irgendwie hat ein blaues Auge, der hat schon was mit Mädchen zu tun, das ist ein krasser Typ, der zieht auf der Schule.
Weil Frauen einem blaues Auge schlagen? Warum hat er das ...
Vielleicht, das weiss er nicht.
Er traut sich auch nicht nachzufragen.
Aber er will Markus gefallen.
Er will der beste Freund von Markus sein, weil er sich denkt,
das muss mein bester Freund werden.
Also geht er zu Markus und sagt,
hey, wollen wir nach der Schule was machen? sich auch nicht nachzufragen, aber er will Markus gefallen, er will der beste Freund von Markus sein, weil er sich denkt, das
muss mein bester Freund werden.
Also geht er zu Markus und sagt, hey, wollen wir nach der Schule
was machen? Und Markus sagt, ja, ich gehe zu Lidl,
was klauen.
Und Matthias versteht plötzlich die Welt nicht mehr.
Warum soll man was klauen? Er hat jetzt auch nicht so viel
Kleingeld, er hat nicht so viel
Taschengeld, aber er würde
trotzdem nie was klauen. Aber er sagt
natürlich, ja, okay, dann komme ich eben mit. Ja, klar, Markus, na klar, machen wir zusammen. Und dann gehen sie los. Und sie klauen was. Und er, Matthias, Markus fragt Matthias. Hey, Matthäus. Markus fragt Matthäus, Markus fragt Matthäus, ey, was sollen wir klauen? Und Matthäus sagt, ich weiss nicht, ich esse diese Cookies ganz gern. Und Markus denkt sich, hä, die Cookies? Ich dachte jetzt eigentlich eher an die Wodkaflaschen. Aber okay, gut, dann kommen wir eben die Cookies. Also, Matthäus hätte niemals in seinem Leben sowas getan, aber hastig, Schweiß erfüllt, die schweissnassen Hände greifen nach der Cookiespackung, er steckt sie hastig in seinen Rucksack, hofft, dass niemand irgendwas gesehen hat, sie verlassen den Lidl, Markus hat schön zwei Red Bull und Wodkaflasche mitgenommen und Matthias jetzt die Kekspackung, er muss sich fast übergeben, er hatte noch nie so viel Angst und Scham in seinem Leben, er will nach Hause gehen, er sagt, okay, wir sehen uns morgen in der Schule, er trifft noch Michael und sagt, oh Gott, ich muss auch zu Max in die Cello-Klasse. Matthäus, Matteo, Max, Matthias, Mattis und Markus. Und Matthias läuft nach Hause und denkt sich, oh Gott, jedes Polizeiauto, das er mir gegenfährt, die haben mich gleich, die haben mich, die sind hinter mir her, die Hunde sind schon auf mich angesetzt, ich muss sofort das Diebesgut loswerden. Diese Cookies sind doch bestimmt GPS getrackt. Ich muss das loswerden, ich muss das Diebesgut irgendwie loswerden. Also, ich verstecke es hier unter dem Baum. Und so kam die Kicks-Packung dorthin. Und Florentin wie so eine Ratte. Hab das Beweismaterial vernichtet. Ah, sehr gut. Oder, letzte These, es ist ein Laster verunglückt. Ein American Cookie Laster. Und du meinst, die Aufräumarbeiten waren so penibel und perfekt, dass alle Cookiepackungen aufgesammelt worden konnten, bis auf die eine. Wie penibel und perfekt können sie gewesen sein, wenn eine übelgeblieben ist? Wir werden es vielleicht nie erfahren, es sei denn, einer von euch da draußen kennt die Antwort.
War der oder die Übel hier drin. Kennt die Antwort und mich würde auch interessieren, habt ihr schon mal was aus dem Fenster geworfen, was waren das für Situationen? Ich bin zweigeteilt, also der Mittelstreifen einer Autobahn ist sicherlich nicht, was man gemeinhin als Natur bezeichnen kann. Ja, das war keine Autobahn, der Landstrasse. Ich weiss, aber so, das ist so ein typischer Ort, wo man ja auch Müll aus dem Fenster wirft. Das ist ja beides im Sinne des, wo wir uns gerade thematisch befinden. Und dieser Impuls, Dinge aus dem Fenster zu werfen, ist mir generell wahnsinnig fremd. Vor allem muss man ja erst das Fenster runterfahren. Also, ich könnte mir eher ein Cabrio vorstellen, wo du wirklich aus dem Impuls heraus so ... Oh, wo es wegliegt! Aha! Wie echt? Du hast Fahrtwind in einem Cabrio? Na klar. Meine Haare sehen nach Cabrio-Fahrten immer und die zahlreich sind. Die zahlreich sind, ja. Das heißt, jemand, ein Cabrio-Besitzer denkt sich, heute ist ja Donnerstag, heute hole ich mein Cabrio aus dem Autohaus ab. Weißt du was? Ich laufe davor noch zu Lidl und hole mir eine Packung Cookies, dann kann ich das richtig feiern, mein Cabrio. Ich verstehe diesen weirden Akt 1 nicht, er kann auch einfach mit dem Auto den Einkauf nach Hause fahren. Nee, weil er fährt jetzt zum Autohaus, um sein Auto abzuholen, sein Cabrio zu holen. Warum braucht man das für die Story? Ich weiß ja schon, was passieren wird, an irgendeinem Punkt wird das wegfliegen. Ich habe mich nur gefragt nur gefragt, warum. Warum hat er Cookies dabei am ersten Tag mit seinem Cabriolet? So, und dann denkt er sich, nee, ach, pass auf, Geschichte. Werner. Werner hat immer gern Kekse im Auto gegessen. Genau, lernt Wilhelm kennen. Und Werner denkt sich, ich liebe Autofahren, ich liebe Kekse. Ich liebe aber auch Luft. Ich kaufe Kabel. Stopp, nein. Und er isst die Kekse am Auto, fröhlich vor sich hin, Radio schallt durchs Auto, aber die Krümel, überall die Krümel. Und Werner hasst Krümel und er hat es schon versucht mit dem Handstaubsauger, er hat es schon versucht mit diesen Sitzüberzügen, er hat es schon versucht mit Pusten, überall, aber überall immer die Krümel in den Ritzen, überall und dann, er hat ja sein Auge auf Agathe geworfen, würde die gerne abholen vom Nagelstudio, aber wie soll Agathe jemals Werner mögen, wenn das Auto aussieht wie ein Saustall? Ja. Werner braucht eine Antwort. Wie kann ich meine beiden Hobbys, Keks essen und ein sauberes Auto kombinieren und plötzlich, er hat die Lösung, ein Caprio. Volle Packung aus dem Fenster werfen. Sorry, ich bin wieder reingrätscht und deshalb habe ich mir eigentlich geschworen, dass ich das nicht mehr mache. Das ist mir eigentlich versprochen. Du wolltest eigentlich, dass du dir sehr sicher bist, bevor du reingrätscht, aber ich habe das Gefühl, die Sicherheit nimmt eher ab. Die Risikobereitschaft nimmt zu. Dieser Akt eins hat nicht geholfen, dass ich wahnsinnig genau weiß, welche Risiko. Okay, das war meine Schuld. Werner denkt sich, ja klar, ein Cabrio. Wenn ich ein Cabrio habe, kann ich weiterhin Kekse mampfen und die Krübel fliegen einfach weg. Wegen des Fahrtwindes die ganze Zeit. Also, Werner stapft sofort zum Cabrio-Auto zum Laden und fährt davor noch mit dem Fahrrad zu Lidl, holt sich eine Keksepackung und sagt sich, das wird ein toller Nachmittag. Auf dem Weg zum Kamin hat er einen Unfall mit Fahrrad. Nein, nein, nein. Und dann...
Fuck, ichmal wäre ich mir crazy sicher, dass es so ist. Er setzt sich ins Cabrio, denkt sich, vielen Dank, Herr Schneider. Wusstet ihr das Fahrrad? Er fährt im Cabrio los, er hat in den Kofferraum gepackt. So, irgendwie muss er ja durchkommen. Fährt also los und fährt auf die Landstrasse, 100 kmh, denkt sich, jetzt kann ich meinen Traum endlich erfüllen. Autofahr-Keks-Action ohne Krümelgefahr. Also packt er aus seinem Rucksack die Packung aus, aber er hat den Fahrtwind unterschätzt, er saß noch nie in dem Cabrio. Wusch, fliegt die Kekspackung in hohem Wagen aus der Hand. Fliegt nicht nur nach oben, sondern nach rechts, damit die Daim in den Graben fallen kann. Wir wissen nicht, wo die Vortices sind, von Cabrio wird es rausgezogen. Kann so gewesen sein. Und dieses Mal stellen wir wieder die Frage, ist es so passiert oder führen wir sie hier mit in das Licht? Das war Jonathan Brakes mit X-Faktor, das Unfassbare. Meinst du, das war seine Idee? Sie sieht doch ein bisschen aus wie Jonathan Frakes. Trägt auch L. Danke. Meinst du, das war seine Idee? Ich liebe ja die Show. Die Mystery finde ich geil, ich moderiere das gerne. Eine Sache nur, ich sage am Ende, bleiben Sie mysteriös bis nächste Woche. Kann ich nicht noch meinen Namen sagen? Also, dass ich meinen Namen sage.
Ja, weil der steht halt schon drauf, ist halt schon X-Faktor das Unfassbare mit Jonathan Frakes.
Ich weiß, ich finde das geil, ich finde das super, ich finde das super, dass Jonathan Frakes steht.
Dann am Anfang steht auch einfach ein Untertitel, auch noch irgendwie, dass Jonathan Frakes.
Finde ich geil, kann ein bisschen grösser machen, aber ich finde es auch geil. Aber wer es nicht ein geiles, der, pass auf, bäh, tschuldige, ich habe gerade einen Burger
gegessen und zum Nachtisch habe ich mir noch ein paar Schokokekste geholt, aber, ähm.
Ja, wo sind die, die sind ja gar nicht dabei.
Die sind doch im Auto.
Sind die aber wirklich im Auto?
Jetzt erst mal zu dem Punkt.
Und zwar dachte ich am Ende, wenn ich am Ende einfach sage,
tschüss, bleiben Sie mir seriös, ich sage einfach meinen Namen noch.
Nee, wie gesagt, weil der wurde ja schon dann sozusagen gesetzt.
Ich verstehe, was du sagst.
Also mehrere Male gesetzt.
Es ist einfach nur, muss man ja sagen, es ist ein guter Name.
John Frakes?
Äh, ist nicht schlecht.
Super, Frakes, also sagt man gerne John Frakes. Ich meine, du heisst Odo Robotskital. Ja, ja. Odo. Das ist ja kein schlechter Name. Es ist kein schlechter Name. Er rollt auch so, weil er so ... Es ist kein schlechter Name, aber es ist jetzt auch kein guter Name. Odo ist ein mehr cooler Name. Odo? Ja. Ja. Odo Robotskital. Ist das ein Odd Robotskital? ist das ein ... Ja, ist das auch ein Ort. Jonathan Frakes, so, bam, Jonathan Frakes, so. Deswegen, ich finde, wenn du einen guten Namen hast, wenn du einen hübschen Schauspieler hast, krieg dein Close-up. Ich bin nicht der schönste Moderator. Das stimmt, Sie sollten vielleicht XL tragen. Stopp. So. Jonathan Frakes sage ich am Ende. Und jetzt gehe ich in mein Auto, dann saß er in seinem Auto, hatte diese Kekspackung, die er sich eigentlich für seine Feierabend-Heimreise geplant hat und dachte, wie hat er gesagt, ich soll XL tragen. Ich trage doch normalerweise L. Also nimmt er die Waffe aus dem Handtüffach? Nee, nein. Also denkt er sich, ja, vielleicht stopfe ich mir doch ein bisschen zu viel sinnlose Kalorien rein. Nutri-Score E. Wir haben ganz, ganz Close-Up auf dieses E. Das ist wirklich Maximum-Close-Up. Kinosaal ist rot erleuchtet. Der Kinosaal wendet sich weg, weil es so grell rot ist. Und Jonathan Frakes sagt sich, nein, heute ist die Wende, heute beginnt der erste Tag meines neuen Lebens und wirft die Packung aus dem Fenster. So, wir haben es endlich geschafft. Ich habe ja nur mal Edamame-Schalen aus dem Fenster geworfen, habe dafür harsche Kritik geerntet, wo ich immer noch sage, meh. Ja, und seitdem ist die Flora oder Fauna in Deutschland belastet durch deine Edamame. In der Kölner Innenstadt, überall Edamame wächst. Über Edamame. Edamame hat in Deutschland keine natürlichen Fressfeinde. Richtig, leider. Die Autobahnen, deswegen alles, was er da, deswegen im Stau kann man aber auch mal dann die Hand rausstrecken und kann man Edamame knallen. Mega gut. Hingegen sind viele Tiere Fressfeinde von Edamame und werden aufgefressen, die Schnecke quasi kaum noch anzutreffen in Köln. Schade. Ja, ich finde es sehr spannend. Wir haben das uns vor einem Reste gestellt. Ich bin gespannt, ob die Hörer das draußen lösen können. Ich würde es mir wünschen, ich kann nicht kaum noch schlafen. Ich will aber dazu noch mal sagen, ich finde, ich trage auch oft XL und es ist jetzt auch nicht schlimm. Also ich verstehe gar nicht, warum das jetzt so ... Nee, es ist nicht schlimm, aber wenn ... Du redest manchmal so schlecht mit dir und über dich. Nein, aber wenn andere Leute deine Grösse bewerten und sie dann ... Das weiß ich auch nicht, was man will. Will man, dass die Leute dir zu kleine Sachen schicken oder zu große? Weil wenn, angenommen sie schicken jetzt M. Ich möchte dafür gewöhnen, dass die Leute mir passende Sachen schicken. Das sowieso, aber wenn nicht passend, willst du dann lieber M kriegen und denkst dir, wow, ich bin fetter, als die Leute denken, dass ich fett bin.
Das ist eigentlich eine schlimme Realisierung.
Bei M denke ich mir, die Leute denken, ich bin just a little boy.
But I'm just a little boy. I'm just a little boy.
Okay, und das ist negativ für dich?
Ja.
Aber ich bin ein kleiner Junge.
Welche Größe hat denn Stefan eigentlich? Ach, der ist doch nur ein Boy. Just a little boy. Der ist doch nur ein little boy. Das war nur ein kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, kleiner, ein kleiner Junge, ein bisschen Little Boy. Ich finde das übrigens super, diese Zahlen L, M, X, ich finde das fantastisch. Nicht irgendwie, mit welcher Hose hast du 44, 39, Stretch, Slim, whatever. Nee, alles einfach nur wie bei McDonald's, klein, gross, medium, bun. Ja, wenn es genormt wäre, wäre ich da auch für. Drei Chancen einfach, drei Möglichkeiten. Ich habe bei Adidas, weil ich brauche, ich bin zu groß, bin zu lang für Jogginghosen. Aber bei Adidas kann man sich L lang. Und man kann sich sogar L lang X kaufen. Das heißt, du hast sozusagen nicht nur eine Large-Grösse in der Länge, sondern eine X-Large-Grösse. Das heisst, du hast L und normalerweise heisst es LL, ist dann L und lang. Eigentlich bräuchte ich ML, also bunt M, aber lange Länge. Und dann kannst du aber MXL. Oh, wow. Und dann habe ich bestellt M2XL. Das ist die Grösste. Das ist aber wirklich schon Abstand. Und das war dann für mich wirklich auch zu lang. Da habe ich mir zu lange Hose an. Habe ich noch nie mit meinem Leben gesehen. Du hast so hochkrempelt, du weißt gar nicht, wie das geht. Nee, habe ich noch nie gelernt. Du hast hochgekrempelt. Nie gelernt. Weil I I'm just a little boy. You just a boy. Bei M denk ich mir, was denken die denn, was ich für ein kleiner Junge bin? Medium. Ja. Medium. Nee. Muss das eigentlich mal geändert werden? Was? Weil die gesamte Bevölkerung wird ja entweder fetter oder dünner oder irgendwas. Dass man einfach mal sagt, neuer Bundeskanzler Friedrich Merz, erster Tag, sagt, Leute, passt auf, M ist jetzt zwei grossen Breiter, weil wir alle richtig fett sind. Kann es passieren, dass man einfach mal alles hochstuft? Ja, ich finde, man sollte da jetzt mal einen Strich, erstmal, was mich auch nervt, generell, manchmal kommt das noch rein, so eine 52.
Was soll denn das sein? 52? Das ist nicht die Kategorie, in die ich denken will. Ja. Macht da auch L draus oder M. Dann bei Hosen. Eigentlich Hosen mag ich gern. Hosen mag ich gern, das sind Inches. Das ist aber egal, aber es ist so, die Hosengrösse, also die Buntgrösse und die Länge zu sagen ist perfekt, das will ich bei Shirts auch eigentlich. Ich will so eine Rumpflänge, da muss man einmal lernen, was ist deine perfekte Shirtgrösse. Eigentlich ist mir M und L und sowas viel zu, weil das sagt ja nichts über die kürze Länge oder die Breite aus. Ja, da hast du natürlich andere Ansprüche, ne? Ich bin da natürlich eher klopsig unterwegs. Nee, du hast so einen Size Zero, du hast so einen ganz normalen Body. Und ich hab so einen langen ... Ja, anscheinend XL. Naja, ist okay. Also, was wir uns dachten als Team, ist ... Mich wundert, dass du so involviert bist in diese Entscheidungen, wie unser Merch versandt wird, an wen. Ich meine, machst du das auch bei Leuten, die das einfach im Shop bestellen, dass du sagst, ach komm, Thorsten, du bist kein L. Nee, das jetzt nicht. Du bist kein L. Nein, das jetzt nicht, aber ich gehe schon auf Insta-Profile und gucke ... Wirklich? Von jedem Einzelnen,, der was bestellt in unserem Merch-Shop, gehst du aufs Instagram-Profil? Manche haben falsche Titel bekommen, das sind aber nicht wirklich falsche Titel. Ich denke mir, ich würde die beige Cap besser stehen. Ach, was ich übrigens gemacht habe jetzt, da könnt ihr euch darauf freuen in den nächsten Folgen, weil eine Person, eine Minaschen-Person hat es jetzt gemacht, hat sich die perfekten Farben, die man tragen soll, ausrechnen lassen.
Also man muss dann Bilder von sich schicken an so eine Farbtheoretikerin, wo dann die Hautuntertöne, Augenfarbe, Hautton, normaler Hautton, alles spielt eine Rolle. Man muss dann ganz viele Fotos von sich hinschicken mit verschiedenfarbigen Shirts oder Oberteilen.
Und dann wird ausgeguckt wissenschaftlich, was man für ein Hauttyp ist. Aber sind die Hauttöne denn so unterschiedlich, dass der eine grün kriegt und der andere gelb? Ja, ganz unterschiedlich. Es gibt wirklich ganz verschiedene, ich habe zwölf verschiedene Farbtypen, die man isst, also so die kalten Jahreszeiten, also man nimmt zum Beispiel, es gibt so so True Winter Typen, die dann vor allem ganz, ganz kalte Töne tragen sollten, wie so superkaltes Blau oder sowas, weil es einfach passt zu der Hautfarbe oder so. Und man kennt das ja, manche Sachen, aber ich habe mir das noch nie gemerkt, aber manche Sachen stehen mir einfach nicht. Manche Sachen gucke ich danach irgendwie jetzt hier ein Video an von uns oder sehe ein Foto von mir und denke mir, wie blass sehe ich denn da aus? Und da hat man einfach etwas angezogen, vielleicht was einem farblich gar nicht so steht. Und da kriegt man jetzt eine, also die Personen in meinem Umfeld haben einen absoluten Breakdown gehabt, weil dann kamen diese Farbtabelle, diese Farbcodes und dann ein Blick in den Kleiderschrank und es gab keine Überschneidung. Das heißt, die sahen ihr gesamtes Leben lang komplett bescheuert aus nach dieser Theorie und jetzt müssen sie sich komplett neu anziehen. Aber, Leute, und ich rieche das Scam, ich rieche vor allem Scam in vielerlei Hinsicht, die wissen ganz genau, welche Kleidung du hast, weil die haben dich auf Instagram gestalkt und die geben dir genau die Farben, die du nicht hast, damit du mehr Kleidung kaufst. Und letzten Endes ist das alles nur von H&M. Zalando, H&M ist es gesponsert, dass du am Ende einfach mehr Kleidung kaufst. Super. Also ich habe da jetzt die Fotos hingeschickt und ich erwarte mein Resultat. Und dann kann ich euch sagen, ob ich ein True Winter, ein Low Autumn oder was auch immer bin. Ich freue mich, euch zu sagen, was ich bin. Clubmitglieder werden es ja mitkriegen mit den Videopodcasts, wenn Stefan einfach von einem Tag auf den anderen wirklich komplett grellgelb einfach hier sitze, grellgelbe Hose, sindgelb und Korall und Lachs. Neonlachs einfach, zack, grell, man muss sich wieder abwenden, wie der da sitzt. Ganz ehrlich, ich bin da, ich weiß genau, wie ich dafür anfällig bin, Farbtheorie, wenn mir da jemand auch nur mit zwei Fachbegriffen akkurat sagt, was ich für nautypisch bin, dann fucking nochmal kaufe ich mir alles in dieser Farbton. Sieht denn jede Mode rückblickend bescheuert aus? Also wir alle kennen das, Bilder von den 90ern, 80ern, man sagt, wie sieht die damals aus? Nee, Kosinus oder Sinus. Sehen alle dumm aus in der Vergangenheit? Nee, nur phasenweise. Wer sieht denn aktuell nicht dumm aus? Ja, 90s, also die ganzen Baggy-Hosen, die zurückkommen, also so Ende 80s, Anfang 90s, das ist doch jetzt voll wieder im Trend. Und so ist es vielleicht so 50er Jahre, so Melone und Anzug, so El Capone, das ist peinlich. Ja, so diese, diese sind jetzt peinlich. Genau, Melonen generell, jede Form von Hut. Ja, ja. Ja, Hüter sind nicht mehr so dabei, das ist schon ... Wobei, dann wiederum habe ich mir den Film Queer angeguckt von Luca Guadagnino, wo Daniel Craig immer einen Hut auf hat. Fantastischer Move natürlich, den immer abzunehmen. Es gibt so viele coole Sachen mit Hut, auch mit Krawatte und mit den Manschettenknöpfen. Ich habe das Gefühl, wir verlieren alle Dinge, die coole Gesten irgendwie erlauben. Und dann ging Fidgety. Regenschirm. Natürlich haben wir einen Fidget Cube und dann sagt irgendwie, mein Opa sagt dann, das haben wir damals nicht gebraucht. Ja, er hatte noch meinen Karabinerabiner in der Hand damals im Krieg. Ja, weil ihr damals einen fucking Manschettenknöpfer hattet oder eure Melone gerichtet habt. Du würdest einen fucking Flammenwerfer im Arm, Opa. Das ist einfach ein Unterschied. Naja, und das war, ja, also deswegen denke ich mir, so ein Hut wäre schon schön. Da habe ich einen Hutmacher, bei TikTok wird mir auch angezeigt. TikTok presst mich auch in, wenn ich mich da nicht wehre, dann presst mich, TikTok denkt auch, ich liebe Magie. TikTok denkt, ich soll den fucking Hut tragen.
Oder einen Magic Shop aufmachen, eins von beiden, also TikTok presst mich so, manche denke ich so, Magier tragen Hüte, ich meine, es kommt langsam alles zusammen, ja, es wird alles auf einen Punkt.
TikTok, seid ihr das da draußen, die mich dann so in so eine neue Phase pressen wollen, so Magier, und ich denke mir bei jedem, ich hasse das, also Kartentricks, macht nichts mit mir.
Ich stelle mir vor, wie ihr euch das gelernt habt
und dann so eure Sprüche auswendig gelernt habt am Schreibtisch.
Das ist doch eh, also das stelle ich mir vor
für so eine Serie, so eine
Master of None-Beziehungsserie,
irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Mehr Referenzen von 2008.
Ja, halt sowas Superbad.
Oder halt so.
So Sopranos The Wire.
Mein Problem ist immer, ich habe immer nur Ideen
für coole einzelne Szenen.
Vielen Dank. Bad oder halt so. Sopranos The Wire. Mein Problem ist immer, ich habe immer nur Ideen für coole einzelne Szenen, aber nie für einen gesamten Film oder eine gesamte Serie. Coole Szenen einzeln aus dem Jahr 2008. Ja, genau. Ich kann sehr spezielle Dinge liefern, aber niemand will sie, und zwar so eine Serie, ja, wir sagen jetzt mal so Comedy, so King of Queens mässig in der Richtung, ja. Und zwar, es gibt, also die Folge beginnt mit, beide finden was am Partner blöd, was sie erneut wollen. Ja, sagen wir mal irgendwie, der eine nimmt zu und die andere hat ein nerviges Hobby oder sowas, hat ein nerviges Hobby. So, und jetzt klauen beide jeweils das Handy vom anderen und versuchen den TikTok-Algorithmus so zu manipulieren. Dahin gehen zu verändern, la vez. Und dann sieht man immer, dass das Auswirkungen hat. Und dann so, ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich so viele Abnehm-Videos angezeigt bekomme. Aber das Gerät sieht ja echt eigentlich ganz praktisch aus. Bestellt sie das Gerät und so. Und dann am Ende braucht man halt noch ein Ende. Das sind gute Anfänge. Und richtig gute Anfänge. Ja, aber ich weiß nicht, wo es dann hingeht, dass die dann merken.
Und dann hast du Arthur, Arthur irgendwie ist, steigt dann komplett. Weg von King of Queens, ist tot auch leider schon.
Ja, aber du musst ja irgendwas andocken so und dann manipulieren die sich gegenseitig.
Weil alle Referenzen, alle Schauspielerreferenzen sind immer von toten Leuten.
Ja, wir brauchen Ben Stiller, wir brauchen wir brauchen Ben Stiller, wir brauchen Vater spielt,
wir brauchen Jennifer Connelly,
so, das sind die Leute, die wir brauchen.
Ach ja, na ja,
oder
am Ende dann
so kommt es raus und dann so,
wie überwache ich meinen Partner auf TikTok
und dann
das ist das Problem an meinen Pitches, so, es sandet zu aus. Oder die wird ganz, ganz dünn dann und hat dann eine Affäre mit dem attraktiven ... Mit dem Trainer, genau, mit dem Trainer, den sie engagiert, um abzunehmen. Und dann everything backfired so hard. Genau, und dann merkt man, wie gut man es eigentlich hatte mit den ... Oder die Partner werden zu perfekt. und man hat dann das, man steht vor dem Problem, dass also beware what you wish for so, also du hast dann das, was du willst, du hast dann die perfekte Freundin, aber das ist dann nicht mehr deine echte Freundin so, die ist dann zwar perfekt und sieht super aus und hat das perfekte Hobby, aber irgendwie das, was du eigentlich an dir mochtest, ihre Einzigartigkeit kommt zurück. Wie sehr magst du Dinge, die du selber für perfekt hältst eigentlich?
Wie gut sind die für dich?
Und dann musst du den Algorithmus wieder ändern, dass sie wieder so ist wie vorher.
Und dann ist am Ende wieder alles wie vorher.
Und dann ist die Folge zu Ende.
Und das ist eine große Analogie darauf, dass TikTok uns ja schon genauso manipuliert wie in dem Beispiel die Partnerin.
Aber auch, dass irgendwie gerade die Unperfektionen in der Beziehung das sind, was interessant ist und dass man vielleicht das mehr schätzen sollte. In diesem Sinne vielen Dank für deine vielen, vielen Imperfektionen, weil das genau das, was dich anscheinend ausmacht. Also ich glaube, ohne die finde ich dich nicht so schön. Ich finde, du könntest noch viel mehr an dir arbeiten, gerade sowas Selbstbewusstsein und Ausstrahlung und Auftreten angeht. Ja, aber dann wäre ich jetzt etwas, was du dann gar nicht mehr so schätzt. Doch, ich glaube, ich würde dich lieber mögen, wenn du besser auftreten würdest. Ich finde, dein Auftreten ist dein Hauptproblem. Hä, aber das widerspricht deinem Kurzfilm. Du hast gute Inhalte, du kannst sie gut präsentieren, nur dein Auftreten finde ich ist so... Ich finde, ist miserabel. Also wie du auftrittst, das gefällt mir überhaupt nicht. Wie meinst du auftrittst? Sobald der Auftritt vorbei ist, dann ist alles in Ordnung. Aber so die ersten, ich finde du hast ganz schlechte erste zwei Minuten. Wenn du in den Raum kommst, die ersten zwei Minuten sind unerträglich. Danach wird es richtig gut, richtig schnell. Weil ich mich meistens, die Leute gratuliere. Du gratulierst jedem Handschlag, egal wie lange ihr euch kennt, jeden Handschlag, jedes Mal. Vielen Dank auch für eure Imperfektionen da draußen. Ja. Weil ohne die wärt ihr nicht, wenn ihr jetzt hier, wenn ihr jetzt hier zuhören. Ja. Oder so. Wenn ihr nicht charakterlich so schäbig wärt, daneben, verfehlt wärt, mangelhaft, falsch, dann wärt ihr nicht hier und würdet uns nicht so ein Danke, dass ihr dabei wart.
Seid nett zu euch.
150 Folgen, wir haben es geschafft, niemand hätte damals gedacht, glaubst du, als wir damals angefangen hätten, dass die Leute gesagt hätten, ja, 450 Folgen machen die locker. Nein, die Leute haben nicht mehr gedacht, dass wir acht Folgen machen. Jetzt sitzen wir hier nach 450 Folgen. Weißt du, wo wir in 450 Folgen sind? 900 Folgen. 900! Unser zehntes Jahr und mir fallen ab und zu so Storys ein, wie sich Leute lustig gemacht haben am Anfang, berühmte Leute über unseren Podcast und dann so den Laut angemacht haben auf der Arbeit, da habe ich auch überlegt, vielleicht sollte man das mal alles erzählen, mal so richtig auspacken, mal so richtig Leute ... Die beste Rache ist ein gutes Leben,, man geht das los.
Naja, vielen Dank, na, haut rein,
macht's gut, vielleicht machen wir noch eine Folge, mal schauen,
aber jetzt des grossen und ganzen sind
wir durch, 450 Folgen ist eigentlich ein gutes
Oeuvre. Es ist alles gesagt,
alles ab jetzt ist bonus. Ab jetzt ist alles
gesagt, genau. Ab jetzt wird
entweder alles wiederholt oder noch mal
leicht umformuliert. Weil du schon anfängst zu wiederholen.
Und ab jetzt geht's noch mal ...
Oder es geht jetzt noch mal komplett von vorn los.
Oder jetzt rückwärts.
Also, Massagesettel, Hotlines, zieht euch wahr, man, macht's gut.
Tschüss, bis zum nächsten Mal.